and what the story is about is the very
common phenomenon that every parent
feels that over time your children
replace you and so the mother gained
notoriety or or attention or security
through her beauty and now her daughter
possesses more Beauty than she and you
know if you have a son you know I don't
but if you're the father of a son it's a
very common thing that people don't talk
much about when when your son brings
home the beautiful girl for prom when
he's 17 you know the father feels some
pride sure but he he also feels some
despair because it until now he's been
the one that women look to and now the
sun is and this is a it's a common
tragedy in life but it's but it's a
beautiful tragedy that overtime our
children replace us and in our
generation where we live now we won't
even have kids for fear of missing out
on any piece of life